Dylan is with us in Marilyn hightailin
now are you okay so I've been listening
for about a year now and due to some
really bad life issues I made some
really bad decisions and I'm now 24 25
thousand in the hole and I just I don't
know how to get out of it
the debt is a credit cards there's $800
on a credit card
23500 and a car loan and then I owe my
mom money for a car I just bought for
her so I could try to get out of the
actual car loan the one with my mom
she's already told me that all my other
bills need to come first but I went to
the dealership trying to sell this car
and they said that I can't make payments
on the difference because I do owe more
than it's worth
so it looks like my only option is to
voluntary surrender or private sell and
try to save the difference and I just
don't know how to get out of this and
it's causing the fight with me and my
girlfriend and I'm stressed about it and
I'm losing sleep over it and I just
don't know where it's causing the fights
with you and your girlfriend um the car
isn't just the financial stress that
I've been under oh just say yeah you're
freaked out and so you're not fun to be
around okay I'm going on with that um so
how old are you 18 holy crud how much do
you owe your mother I heard about 800
bucks oh good okay and what do you make
um if I work 60 hour weeks I can make
the $1,600 every two weeks so 3,200 a
month so you're making about 50,000
bucks a year that's grosser than that um
take home that um take home okay yeah so
you're making about 50 grand what do you
do I work at Amazon I'm a load trucks
okay
all right and and what is the Kelley
Blue Book private sale on the car that
you owe 23,500 on private sale is about
19,000 okay so you're four thousand five
hundred dollars off and the dealership
won't work with you on that who do you
owe them money to capital who Chrysler
Capital Chrysler no they will not let
you work out the difference no none of
the car financing companies will having
paid off and they said that only option
was to cover the difference voluntary
surrender no that's not the only option
you gotta cut you got to cover the
difference you do not want a voluntary
surrender this car we're gonna work this
out okay okay how much is your rent $800
a month okay all right so here's the
thing to start with we're gonna take a
little pressure off and you don't have
to pay your mom anything right now and
when you sit down and do a written
detailed budget with $3,200 coming in
and you pay the payment on the rent and
you buy some food to eat and you keep
gas in your car and you work 60 hours a
week or more you have the money to pay
the car payment for right now it's a
dumb purchase it was crazy you shouldn't
have bought it and yes you need to get
rid of it but you do not have to turn it
in you can pay the payment for now okay
I don't want you to keep it I'm gonna
help you get out of it but you need to
get yourself organized with your monthly
expenses on a budget so go to every
dollar and download the every dollar app
and when I take 3200 - 800 for your rent
- some money for food and gas and - a
car payment I got money left over here
now you're not going out every night
partying and your little girlfriend may
not see you for a while unless she wants
to come over and watch TV but uh we're
not gonna be running around spending
money on anything we're in the middle of
a crisis agreed yeah agreed I don't I'm
not a partier anyway okay
good so we just got to get you organized
because you have the ability to make
enough to pay these bills for now but
then we have to get you out of this car
because it's land of stupid all right so
we need $4,500 there's two places we can
get that one is you could save it up or
two is you could borrow it somewhere
else okay so I want you to go talk to
your local credit unions around the area
I want you to go talk to some small
small banks in the area and see if you
can scratch up a $5,000 personal loan
crap man even if you put it on a credit
card you would be five thousand dollars
in debt instead of twenty three thousand
dollars in debt it would be a good move
agreed yeah now so you're already in
debt all we're doing is restructuring
and reducing the overall debt by getting
rid of this car so you need the four
thousand five hundred and then you need
a buyer you don't need a buyer till you
have the money
okay and don't borrow the money just get
the loan arranged okay so the bank has
approved if the credit union is approved
if they say you can come get five
thousand then you put the car up for
sale and then a buyer comes along and
hands you a 19 thousand dollar check you
run over at the bank pick up the $5,000
loan put it with the 19 thousand dollar
check send it to Chrysler they send the
title you give it to the buyer that's
how this works okay okay now that's
gonna get you out of the car you do not
voluntary repo it here's why they will
sell the car after repo voluntary or
otherwise not for 19 thousand not for
fifteen thousand but for about ten
thousand it's a repo sale and guess what
they're gonna sue your butt for the
difference thirteen thousand five
hundred bucks if I'm right on my pricing
and so you go from a minor problem to a
major problem okay you lose control of
the sale price when you hand them the
keys you follow me yeah and you got to
cover the difference either way so of
course you'll have a Reapers
on your credit which is you know like a
foreclosure a bankruptcy or an IRS lien
these are the four worst things that can
happen to your credit and/or car repo
and so we don't want to start you out at
18 years old with that that's not a good
plan so we're gonna we're gonna get
tight on the budget beans and rice rice
and beans no life we're paying rent car
payment and food and gas and that's
about it and we're gonna hold on hold on
hold on until we can either save up the
four thousand five hundred or we can get
a loan for four thousand five hundred or
five thousand or whatever it is and we
get a buyer lined up with it and get the
car sold if that takes you three or four
months you can make it if it takes you
five months you can make it I don't want
it to I want you to get rid of the
stupid car I want it out of your life
and I want the stress gone just for you
okay and then you've learned your lesson
you're not gonna borrow money anymore
and for God's sakes don't borrow money
from a relative anymore stop borrowing
money but the good news is you can clean
up those other two little debts real
fast eight hundred and eight hundred
right yeah soon as we get this car
problem solved but I want you to pay
minimum payments on those right now and
let's get this car problem solved as
fast as we possibly can so let's save up
the four thousand five hundred or get a
loan and get out of the car did all that
makes sense to you yes any questions um
do you do you still think all the other
factor in they'll probably be about two
hundred and fifty dollars worth of
insurance costs come on yeah okay three
thousand two hundred
how much is your car payment 480 okay so
three thousand two hundred coming in in
a month right yeah - 800 - 480 -
insurance - gasps - food I still got
money left dude you follow me on the
math or whatever do so whatever is left
over do you want me to save it put that
into a debt snowball or simply put it in
the savings cuz we got
we're trying to come up with a 4500 if
you can't get it borrowed from a credit
union okay if you get it borrow from a
credit union and you get rid of your car
then you start using it to work your
debt snowball and get these debts paid
off so when you lose $5,000 on this car
I want you to remember this the rest of
your life you learned a very valuable
lesson as a very young man and you don't
have to learn it twice the bad news is
you paying $5,000 in stupid tax the good
news is you learn not to impulse a
stupid but car again and never borrow
money on one again that'll change your
whole life if you learn that lesson
right now at 18 years old